in the opening scene we are introduced
to an insurance broker named Elaine
Duvall who is busy playing video games
on his computer soon after he is
interrupted when he receives a phone
call from his wife Marie instructing him
to meet her at a specific location it
turns out Elaine was supposed to meet
her to look for a prospective new house
but he completely forgot about it
nonetheless he hurries to the location
and joins Marie where they meet with a
real estate agent named Frank chase
after the introductions Frank guides
them through the house and showcases its
notable features including a spacious
living room a well-appointed kitchen and
an inviting bedroom while exploring the
property Marie's attention is drawn to
an abandoned junk car nearby prompting
her to inquire about it Frank assures
her that he will have the car removed
very soon in the next scene despite
being impressed with the house overall
the couple find it somewhat oversized
for their needs so they begin
contemplating whether or not to proceed
with the purchase hearing their doubts
Frank reveals that the house has a
secret which makes it the most unique
how in the world he then takes them to
the basement and unveils a manhole cover
claiming that a life-altering secret
Lies Beneath the couple is hesitant at
first as they believe that the manhole
merely leads to a sewer but Frank
manages to convince them to venture down
ultimately the couple follows the shrewd
real estate agent and descends into the
depths of the basement much to their
astonishment the tunnel leads them to
the first floor of the very same house
they were in moments ago that's not even
all the couple realizes that it is now
daytime despite entering the tunnel in
the evening overwhelmed with shock
Elaine and Marie turned to Frank for an
explanation the agent then explains that
this tunnel causes anyone who enters to
reverse aging by three days but makes
time Fast Forward by 12 hours that means
that the couple are now three days
younger than before with this
realization Marie becomes a bit excited
as she has always wanted to live past
100 hence she convinces her husband to
purchase the house the scene then cuts
to a few days later and we see that
Elaine and Marie have settled
comfortably into their new home in order
to celebrate the occasion they share a
drink together a few more days pass by
and Elaine gets back to his regular
routine while Marie becomes increasingly
obsessed with the basement tunnel
prompting her to repeatedly Venture
through it in hopes of getting younger
on a particular day Elaine's boss Gerard
accompanied by his girlfriend Jean who
pays a visit to their new home upon
arrival Gerard's attention is
immediately drawn to the abandoned car
in the junk being a car Enthusiast he
examines the vehicle and suggests the
lane should restore and utilize it
emphasizing its exceptional quality
however Elaine who has little interest
in cars does not pay much attention to
his suggestion meanwhile as the
conversation unfolds Maria emerges from
the tunnel and joins the Gathering here
it is revealed that she had entered the
tunnel the previous day later on the
four of them gather for dinner during
which Gene urges her boyfriend to
disclose his new secret as a result
Gerard hesitantly reveals that he has
recently underwent an electronic penis
trance
he's got himself an electronic penis
transplant and he Now controls it using
his smartphone he can make it stand this
is sit and even dance the Revelation
creates an awkward moment but Gerard
casually dismisses it stating that it
represents modern technology after this
Elena also contemplates sharing the
secret of their new home but Marie
vehemently forbids him from doing so
later the guests leave and Marie
requests her husband to accompany her to
the time traveling portal but he
declines citing that he has a lot of
work because of this she angrily enters
the portal alone the next day at work
Elaine is engaged in a fun conversation
with one of the clients when he is
summoned to Gerard's office upon
entering his cabin Gerard asks how
Elaine feels about his new electronic
transplant in response Elaine talks
positively stating that organ
transplants have become very common in
today's generation he further explains
that he's not going to judge Gerard for
it making him happy back at home Marie
descends from the time traveling portal
after 12 hours and becomes fixated on
her photographs from when she was young
her ultimate goal is to get back to her
become a model just then an idea comes
in her mind and she places a mirror in
front of the Portal's exit this way she
can assess any Visible Changes in her
appearance each time she gets out of it
after this A desperate Marie once again
heads down to the basement and enters
the portal 12 hours later she emerges
only to find that Elaine is already
asleep Marie rudely awakens him and asks
if he notices any difference in her
appearance however Elaine disappoints
her by stating that she appears the same
as before following this he tells her
about a cat which he found at the
basement earlier that day he says that
the cat sat on the basement's hatch and
meowed to him as if it was trying to
tell him about the portal assuming it to
be a warning sign Elaine suggests that
they permanently shut the portal down
however Marie dismisses his concerns
saying that he is overthinking the
situation firm in her belief she once
again heads towards the basement and
enters the portal the following day
Elaine visits Gerard's office to discuss
business matters but the latter diverts
their conversation and asks him out on a
shooting practice session instead as
they arrive at the shooting range Gerard
enthusiastically fires various guns
while Elaine who is unfamiliar with such
activities observes from the sideline
Gerard sets his electronic penis to
Bullseye shortly after as Gerard is
handling a shotgun he experiences some
strong recoil that startles him and
throws him off balance the aftermath of
the accident leaves Gerard with a severe
injury to his transplanted penis
unfortunately because of this he loses
control over his transplanted organ now
it can no longer dance overwhelmed with
panic Gerard tells everything to Elaine
and the latter suggests that he repair
it however it is not that easy as the
entirety of Europe lacks the necessary
expertise for the procedure given the
Gerard's transplant took place in Japan
but despite his busy schedule Gerard
decides to travel to Japan for the
necessary repairs before his departure
he entrusts Elaine with full
responsibility for the business and
requests that he take care of Gene later
in accordance with his boss's
instructions Elaine goes to the
bookstore where Gene works and lies to
her that Gerard has left the country on
a business trip however she remains
skeptical and harbor suspicions that
Gerard may be involved with other women
as a result she also makes sexual
advances towards Elaine but he firmly
rejects her and walks away on the other
hand despite Marie's repeated Journeys
through the time traveling portal she
fails to notice any significant changes
in her appearance assuming that the
portal isn't working she decides to
conduct an experiment using a rotten
apple surprisingly when she goes inside
the portal and emerges with the Apple it
is no longer rotten this reveals that
the portal is indeed working the same
night Marie shares her Discovery with
her husband suggesting that the portal
really does have the power to reverse
the aging process however Elaine who is
completely uninterested and frustrated
with Marie's obsession over the portal
dismisses her Discovery he openly admits
that he has other important things to
worry about this Sparks a heated
argument between the husband and wife in
the midst of this turmoil Elaine takes a
bite from the same experiment at Apple
only to discover that it is infested
with ants this deeply concerns him as he
believes that his wife is also been
Infested by the same insects hence he
quickly rushes her to a clinic upon
arrival they meet the doctor and inquire
if it's possible for a human body to
contain living ants within however the
doctor believes that they are joking and
sends them away angrily on their way
back home Elaine expresses his fear that
Marie might only appear youthful on the
outside while aging rapidly internally
however the greedy woman remains adamant
to become a renowned model and
immediately upon reaching home Marie
disregards her husband's pleas and
promptly descends to the basement to
enter the portal once again meanwhile in
Japan Gerard is seen undergoing the
necessary repairs for his transplant in
the process he contacts Elaine and
requests him to purchase a birthday gift
for Gene Elaine hesitates as he knows
nothing about the girl but his boss
insists on him doing so asking him to
select something girlish as a result
Elaine makes his way to a nearby
supermarket where he selects a purse as
a gift following this he exits the store
and coincidentally runs into Frank
taking this opportunity Elaine inquires
about the potential Health implication
patients of using the time traveling
portal in response Frank advises him to
use the portal very moderately
cautioning that excessive use can lead
to severe physical and psychological
consequences in addition Frank suggests
that sealing the portal might be the
best course of action if it is getting
too Troublesome with this advice in mind
Elaine proceeds to Gene's workplace to
present her with the gift however upon
arrival he witnesses her making out with
another man prompting him to walk away
quickly as days go by Marie's obsession
with regaining her youth intensifies
driving her to spend the majority of her
time within the portal Elaine attempts
to bring her back to normalcy but this
only results in further arguments
between the two at one point Elaine
contemplates sealing the portal to put
an end to the chaos yet Marie adamantly
stops him from doing so on the other
hand Gerard returns to France after
successfully resolving his transplant
issue however he has not come alone he
is actually made a new girlfriend whom
he ultimately marries but because of
Gerard's dancing stick the marriage
doesn't last long and they are
eventually separated after this Gerard
experiences a series of unsuccessful
relationships with other women one
fateful day he is driving along the
highway when a sudden fire engulfs his
transplant the unexpected distraction
causes his vehicle to Skid off the road
and flip over tragically leading to his
demise the movie then cuts to several
years later after passing through the
time portal thousands of times Maria
eventually emerges from it as a youthful
19 year old girl however despite her
transformed appearance she doesn't find
happiness as she struggles in her
attempts to become a model this leads to
mounting frustration which gradually
affects her mental well-being one day
Marie reaches a peak point and
experiences a severe mental breakdown
because of which she has to be admitted
to a mental care hospital while she is
away Elaine finally closes the portal
putting an end to their time traveling
escapades the final scene depicts the
hospital where Marie consumed by her
inner anxiety shatters a glass and then
tries to commit the unthinkable but to
her shock the wound unveils a disturbing
Revelation Murray's body is also
infested with ants meaning that the
portal had been corrupting her all along
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching